ralf h steht unter mordverdacht er soll
vor 27 jahren die 16 jährige nicole
scharrer ermordet haben jetzt ist er
wieder frei und spaziert durch münster
der grund für seine freilassung ist
unter anderem corona am 14 oktober 1993
ist die damals 16 jährige nicole
scheller auf dem nachhauseweg gegen 22
uhr 45 steigt in der nähe ihres
elternhauses in dortmund aus dem bus
durch zu hause kommt sie nie an ein
fremder mann soll ihr gefolgt sein
am nächsten morgen findet eine
zeitungsbotin die leiche in einem
gebüsch unweit einer grundschule nicole
wurde missbraucht und erdrosselt einen
tatverdächtigen ermittelt die polizei
erst 25 jahre später im juni 2018
eine hauptschule auf dem körper hat die
beamten auf die spur von ralf h aus
münster gebracht möglich wurde das durch
eine neuartige analyse von dna spuren
habe festgenommen und muss sich ab
dezember 2018 vor dem landgericht
dortmund verantworten
in handschellen wird er in den saal
geführt er verdeckt sein gesicht die
schreckliche tat wird ralf h im laufe
des prozesses abstreiten
joachim und sigrid schaller die eltern
der toten verfolgen den prozess als
nebenkläger sie waren zum tatzeitpunkt
in den herbstferien 1993 in holland
urlaub hatten noch mit ihrer tochter
telefoniert und sich auf das wiedersehen
gefreut
doch dann wurde nicole ermordet obwohl
der fall so lange zurückliegt sind beide
eltern in psychologischer betreuung im
märz 2020 platz dann plötzlich der
prozess am 27
verhandlungstag eine richterin war
langfristig erkrankt im august sollte
der prozess von vorn beginnen
doch nun wurde ralf h überraschend aus
der untersuchungshaft entlassen
das entschied das oberlandesgericht in
hamm ein tatverdacht bestehe weiterhin
obwohl lebenslange haft droht sei die
untersuchungshaft nicht mehr
verhältnismäßig so das gericht dem
angeklagten seien die
verfahrensverzögerungen durch die justiz
und zuletzt aufgrund der korona pandemie
nicht anzulasten
das neue verfahren beginnt nun am
vierter august vor dem landgericht
dortmund und bianca weiner steht für uns
jetzt an der haltestelle dort wurde
nicole damals das letzte mal lebend
gesehen guten morgen janka besteht denn
fluchtgefahr für den täter ist jetzt
wieder auf dem auf freiem fuß gut
fluchtgefahr besteht natürlich immer
wenn jemand nicht im gefängnis ist aber
der prozess beginnt am 4
89 mit einem neuen gericht als mit neuen
richtern wieder direkt von vorne also
neue beweisaufnahme zeugen müssen neue
aussagen
ich kann mir vorstellen dass der
angeklagte sich die verhandlungen
wahrscheinlich anschaut wie verläuft der
prozess geht alles gut ist kann er
durchaus immer noch seien durch
irgendwelche umstände dass er eventuell
frei gesprochen wird
dann kann man vielleicht an seiner
stelle legen
wie läuft der prozess für mich geht es
auf einen schuldspruch hinaus dann
könnte es eventuell sein dass er kurz
vor ende eventuell verschwindet aber an
seiner stelle würde ich ja erst mal
schauen wie läuft der prozess aber wie
gesagt fluchtgefahr besteht natürlich
immer
er muss sich nicht bei der polizei
melden kleine auflage erhalten ganz
normal auf beim kunden und was macht er
jetzt wo hält er sich aktuell auf wissen
wer was darüber also er hat immer noch
eine wohnung die stets seit zwei jahren
leer
aber nachbarn haben wir berichtet dass
er sich in einer gartenlaube seiner
lebensgefährtin auffällt wie hatte
einer kleingartenanlage ja eine ziemlich
große parzelle knapp 800 quadratmeter
dort ist er scheinbar die woche über
schläft auch dort und da hält er sich
mit seiner lebensgefährtin aktuell auf